once again it'd be fun to show you some  new year's resolutions made by people  right here in our studio audience I  think I'd be a nice thing to do for  example this resolution right here  instead of chest bumps start greeting my  Bros with a lingering hug and a kiss on  the nose and this one and every sentence  I say with ladies there's this one same  as every year punch dudes in the dick  there's this one figure out some way  anyway to let people know I'm really  into bikes  where's this one go see that sweet young  woman I met at the diner and finally let  her out of my woodshed and finally never  again let my husband pick which talk  show we attack  [Applause]  you